Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
in the book of prayer
regarding the chapters
listing the places
where it is impermissible
for a person to pray.
The places where it is impermissible for
a person to pray. Now yesterday we
discussed the framework for this and
that is that
where if I were to ask the question
where is it permissible to pray
everywhere except right it's kind of
like
Adam
in paradise
eat from anywhere you in this
paradise
except so there's a couple of dots right
on the map that are impermissible but
the essence of the earth is that it is
all permissible and it is all pure and
it is all purifying. There is no excuse
a person may have who is conscious who's
unable to pray. There's literally
a
an accommodation for prayer everywhere a
person goes. In the previous nations,
they had to pray in specific places.
They had to pray in a church, in a
synagogue, in a this ummah may pray
everywhere. Alhamdulillah,
except for a number of places. Those
places can be counted on one hand.
The first of those places we briefly
touched on yesterday and that is where
huh
the graveyard or at any grave in general
because
when we say graveyard
that could mean a place
designated
for graves.
But what about if I find a place in the
graveyard that doesn't have any graves
in it? Is it permissible? The answer is
no. It's still impermissible,
which we will get to the evidence of
that in a moment, inshallah. But it is
impermissible
to pray at a grave, any grave site, even
if there is just a solitary grave there,
it is impermissible to pray there. And
we mentioned the narration of Jundab
Abdah
and many others of the companions in
Bkari and Muslim 5 days before our
prophet sallall.aii wasallam departed
this earth and moved on to a much better
place and a much better company. He
uttered the words
[Silence]
Abdah tells us that 5 days before our
beloved prophet sallall.aii wasallam
departed from this earth. He said indeed
the previous nations, the people who
you know the previous nations before you
used to make a habit of taking the
graves of their prophets and righteous
as places of worship.
Indeed, I I hereby prohibit you from
doing so. Do not take the
grave sites as messaged as places for
salah for sujud as places of worship.
He then mentions
so this narration means anywhere where
there's a grave, right?
But then if a person's in a cemetery and
there's a whole place that is completely
free of graves, is it permissible to
pray there? Here we have another
narration also in a on the authority of
who says
he says all of the earth is a place of a
masid. All right. And as we mentioned,
these two narrations, they explain to us
each other
because a person could say, well, the
previous narration that says do not take
the grave sites as a masid. Well, that
could mean just don't build a masid at a
grave site. We say no, it's more broad
than that. Do not pray at any grave
site. How is that? Because Allah has
made the entire earth as a what? As a
masid. Correct. So this means that the
entire earth has the ruling of a masid.
Do you have to wake up in the morning
and make masid in your bedroom? Of
course not. What it means is that the
entire earth is a place for salah.
And that's what's intended here. Here in
this narration, the messenger of Allah
sallall.aii wasallam says, "All of the
earth, all of the land is a masid except
for the cemetery and the ham."
The cemetery,
a place that is designated
for burial.
This is a place that is impermissible to
pray. So that's number two. Number three
is Alam.
This is a very good example of
modern Arabic
causing us to misunderstand ancient
Arabic.
And I'll give you an example here.
The ancient words of Arabic, we still
use them, but modern Arabic has given
them new meanings.
because of our culture, because of
whatever. And so what ends up happening
is if we take the current meanings of
those words and apply them to the
meanings of the prophet's words, this is
where mistakes happen. Sai wasallam. So
for instance, for those of us here who
know Arabic, what is a m
what is a mul?
an actor, right? There's a narrations.
The prophet sallall.aii wasallam says
Allah has cursed
the mum.
Some have translated this to say Allah
curses actors. That's not that's not at
all what the narration is talking about.
in the ancient Arabic is mutilating the
dead on the battlefield.
If you kill an enemy soldier to mutilate
them, right? To carve them up to, you
know, do things that people do with with
dead bodies. He says Allah has cursed
the mutilators. A m
in ancient Arabic language is someone
who mutilates a corpse. is not an actor.
This is a modern
meaning of a common word. Right?
Another example.
What is in modern Arabic? Does anyone
know
an atom? Yeah. They say
physics is referred to as knowledge of
which is plural for
is an atom.
But we have in the Quran a
right. So if I explain that verse with
the modern meaning, whoever does an
Adam's weight of good will be rewarded
accordingly. And whoever does an Adam's
weight of bad will be punished
accordingly. Is that what the verse
says? No, it is not.
A zra in the Arabic language is the
tiniest tiniest tiniest ant.
You know the little ants that are so
tiny you can't even really see their
legs.
It just looks a dot moving around.
That's a dra. And it is considered to be
an analogy for something tiny in the
Arabic language. Right?
And so that is what the verse is
speaking about. It has nothing to do
with Adams,
right? And here is another example.
Alham
what is a ham in modern Arabic? A
bathroom, right? But that's not what the
narration is talking about. I mean even
our term bathroom
is not what old English means bathroom.
What is a bathroom? A bathroom is where
baths are taken. A ham is taken from the
root word alham. And it is where water
would be heated and people would come
and it's a bath house. People would go
to bathe there, right? , you know,
it's a modern-day sauna or if
you've ever been to those Turkish baths
for those
bougie folks amongst us, may Allah, you
know, keep you comfy and bougie. But
those who have traveled, you know, you
you go to those bathous where you go,
you get a massage and you sit in the
sauna and you're bathed with the
very hot water. It's all steamy. It's a
group place. That's what a ham is in the
prophet's time sai wasam. It's a place
where people congregate to bathe. It's a
shower house. And this is what is
meant by a hamm.
We associate in modern English a
bathroom with the bathroom that's
in every house, right? Where that it has
a toilet. It doesn't even have to have a
bath in it to be a bathroom. It's a
place where you go to relieve yourself.
That's not a bathroom in the prophet's
time. In modern Arabic,
it means the same thing as a bathroom in
modern English.
But if we understand this, we understand
that it is impermissible to pray in a
sauna. It's impermissible to pro pray
pray in a place a
a public swimming pool. It's imper
impermissible to pray in a bath house,
right? Any place that where people
congregate and have their clothing off
in congregation. This is a place that
prayer in it is invalid.
prayer in it is invalid whether it has a
toilet in it or not. Right? A toilet.
This is
this is a different ruling altogether.
But when the prophet says that it is
impermissible to pray in a mb a cemetery
and a ham is a bath house
and the scholars have defined this as a
place where people go to bathe in
congregation together.
It's a public place or a private place
but people gather there to
you know bathe and for this reason
there's ex extreme narrations regarding
a ham. If we understood ham to be a
bathroom
there's narrations where the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam says no woman who
believes in Allah in the last day would
ever go to a ham.
Would we would we would we
translate that to mean no woman who
believes in Allah in the last day would
ever go to the bathroom? This makes no
sense, right? It's a ham. It's a
congregational place where people take
their clothes off and bathe or marinate
or whatever it is that they do. So,
these are three places that we've taken
so far. a grave site, a cemetery and a
bath house. These are three places where
salah is invalid. If a person makes
salah there, it's invalid. And we will
mention the fourth tomorrow inshallah.
be in a Muhammad.